and there are more than 154 000
confirmed coronavirus deaths now in the
u.s
and the white house says the epidemic is
now entering a new phase
chris martinez reports now from los
angeles
the cdc is citing a projection model
that estimates more than
eighteen thousand new coronavirus deaths
nationwide
in the next three weeks what we're
seeing today is different from march and
april
it is extraordinarily widespread dr
debra burks warns the nation's outbreak
is entering a new phase affecting rural
areas
to everybody who lives in a rural area
you are not immune or protected from
this virus
but many americans still refuse to
follow the guidelines
nearly one thousand people attended a
boat party in east peoria illinois this
weekend
seemingly unconcerned about catching the
virus
definitely not not at all
and south dakota is getting ready to
welcome more than two hundred fifty
thousand bikers
for the annual sturgis motorcycle rally
in central indiana
a school is temporarily closing two days
after opening
after at least one staff member tested
positive
there is a ray of hope in california
which has more confirmed cases than any
other state
hospitalizations and hard hit los
angeles county have dropped
over the past week chris martinez cbs
news
los angeles